the Joe Rogan experience but he ever try
to make a move on you oh yeah when you
were a kid yeah couple times from five
to how old the the scariest one was when
I was 13 when I was 13 I was in Boston
one time it happened before but a
librarian saved me I was like eight I
was in San Francisco and I was really in
a monster books back then I was in the
monster movies and monster books and I
was looking at these books and this
creepy dude came over to me and he said
do you like monster books and I said
yeah and he said well I have monster
books in my car do you want to come see
him I said okay so I was 8 years old
that was dumb started walking behind him
and the librarian screams out Joseph you
get away from him he just got out of
jail I'm like oh my god and the guy ran
and I ran to the librarian and she
hugged me and I was crying it was very
scary
I got a call with a guy who's freezing
that bus wasn't common whoa had the
basketball I was that same michaels jim
I got on County Boulevard next thing you
know [ __ ] there's no number one bus
I'm that [ __ ] that one happened and
below you know I pulls up you want a
ride yeah I get in there I still
remember how he acted like from the
beginning from the minute I got in
something wasn't right as energy wasn't
right
and he thought he had he thought he had
pray yeah we're on a stick he was like
we were we were 18 and we were taking a
girl back to our apartment you know what
kind of clumsy he was clumsy I got the
light he went for the boy he liked
playing basketball he went for the ball
he'd touch my dick like he slipped Oh
Kevin Spacey you like it and I was like
well I can't like it and Joe Rogan the
dope
it was like God opened the [ __ ] door
I just got out and ran Oh
he kept saying come back I was just
teasing it come on I'll give you a ride
I was already home I was over at the top
of shits important
like give a [ __ ] but that was basic and
I always think about that like why
didn't people approach Brian I knew
today looking back I still remember
three guys and my high school teacher
that would come on as a basketball guru
and I found that and I always thought a
little weird about am I married you know
and then years ago somebody said yeah he
was sucking kids I had a guy slow
playing me at a lake there was a guy
that used to run around the lake and
talk to us with more efficient but
probably like 13 me and my friend Josh
in particular we would go this one Lake
it was in our town and we'd fish there
all the time
and this dude would come by all the time
and visit he was always friendly start
off real normal what do you guys up to
catches the fish like southern accent
seems I got an old gentleman and then a
couple of times he came when it was just
me and then he just sat down next to me
and talked to me and I was naive I was
13 I just thought he was a real nice guy
like almost like a older brother type
figure it's gonna give you a good advice
he talked about cool [ __ ] he was a
teacher he got kicked out of his
position for some unfair reason he
wouldn't really be specific about it but
he said you know they didn't like the
way he taught and so anyway this dude
just becomes my friend like nice and
slow nice and slow brings me lunch I
even went to his house once and then one
day I am fishing and he's drunk and he
tells me he loves me and I said I think
I said something like I really like you
too
he goes you know there there can't be
love without sex and I remember thinking
what whoa like what did he just what
happened
and then I might remember thinking what
a dummy I am
I thought this guy just liked me he was
I was his buddy that he's gonna teach me
things he just likes teaching people
it's just really smart but I had my hand
on a knife
a Swiss Army knife from them a little
red plastic ones you know the ones with
the camel yeah they have all the kind of
[ __ ] and all I was thinking is I put it
in my hand in my pocket like I held on
to it and I remember thinking god damn
it I hope I don't have to [ __ ] try to
use this cuz I was thinking it's like he
was a big guy you know I was 13 I don't
know what I weighed 120 pounds or
something I'm like [ __ ] this guy might
beat the [ __ ] out of me and raped me
here in the woods like he was bigger
than me and he was always jogging you
know it wasn't in bad shape
and he I told him get the [ __ ] away from
me and he told me not be upset and then
I left I got away he didn't chase me I
you know he didn't want to be violent he
wanted to trick me another [ __ ] you come
he wanted he didn't want to rape me he
wanted to trick me into [ __ ] him I
got real lucky that that was the case
but then years later I got a letter from
I'm at my house the hell was creepy cuz
it showed up in the mailbox like he had
figured out where I moved to and sent me
a letter
oh whoa and it was like real like
friendly and professional like a real
professor like a scholar I don't even
remember if he ever apologized but it
was real weird it was like whoa I dodged
that bullet
how many guys that are like that but
aren't nice they just want to get you
clothes and then rape you that's much
more likely probably that is some
horrific [ __ ] man what Paulo Rican
Nelson I went to his house that's her
name
that's what we called him he was boarder
Rican and his name was Nelson Hey look
I'm giving that terrorist a he lived
next to the old Tino's but in the back
and I think he raped guys with a black
dude like there was a black friend of
his that would come over then and they
give you a beer uh-huh and all that [ __ ]
so he took you in as you like [ __ ] type
a kid like you always like you want to
see some good [ __ ] and then that's how
it started then they'll bring you over
there you go in and he start with the
first whoo yeah bring your buddies any
time you want then it was a pawn and
then we got a Snickle bags of weed
he started will I'll get you weed and
then he introduced our black friend to
him and I said this black friend just
looked [ __ ] [ __ ] like his afro
was cut weird he had weird hair and I
remember him distinctively speaking
about the Rock of Gibraltar I had just
come back from Africa Louie young kid
it's like wow and then once he showed us
to pull and it came out like a week
later somebody said bro
that dudes no good I'll ask what's his
name he went over there the air man he
has no figured suckers there so we're
like what are we do we call the cops or
do we tell carmine were like no let's
just play the guy cuz he was selling US
wheat he was like a bartender in the
city and was selling sweet and then he
pursued the porno thing with us he's
like you guys to understand you know and
then he talked us into he like I'm gonna
[ __ ] my girlfriend come over and listen
we would come over there at night and
listen that he would leave the window
open and it was his girlfriend and him
[ __ ] up and she would be saying give
it to Kimmy milk daddy daddy and we like
get creeped out right I live one day and
then one day we actually [ __ ] on went
back then they'd be he got normal I
think with the misunderstanding with the
one guy he got normal like we somebody
checked them and he got normal and then
like the next summer wasn't he would
come out and play football with us with
a robot with no wonder was Ditka and
we're like what the [ __ ] is this guy
doing like he went to desperate measures
version and I think mrs. an Adi said
something to him you can't be doing that
around here with your dick out and he's
like no no I just want to get exercise
or something like he told us something
weird and that was the end of that
[Applause]